it's the it's the I want to say the top
of the ninth
no top of eight
bottom eight because they were hitting
yeah it was a bottom of the eighth and
you see showy warming up I'm going down
there and it was 912 I think right so
when I saw him going down there I was
like oh boy here we go you knew it was
gonna happen you knew it was coming
and and
uh McNiel gets on I head into a double
play
so take me when you saw him in the
eighth inning Warren going down to
warming up what was your thought because
you know you had to face him this is
like this is like the perfect storybook
ending for sure for sure
um in the eighth inning what were you
thinking
what was I thinking I was like I'm gonna
get a chance to get him right here and
you know I
I don't think I've I honestly I haven't
I haven't faced him in live BP oh
nothing nothing so I haven't seen them I
just seen him from behind okay you know
I mean so I I know what he can do from
behind you that's just the the movements
I see it moving crazy yeah I missed some
pictures I should have hit yeah but I
mean yeah like that picture I should
have hit right there yeah but bro
I understand it's a hundred cutting I
understand like that you know what I'm
saying and so okay so you're on Deck I
head into a double play Boom now you're
walking to the plate what what's going
through your mind bro what's going
through Mike Trout I gotta go deep here
I gotta go deep here I think it might
have messed me up because it took me out
of my Approach but yeah yeah there was
one thing in my mind I was trying to
take him deep I mean there's no other
there's no other
there's no other explanation
you know I mean you know how it is I
know exactly what you're saying I I know
exactly and I think I think one time I
think I've gone deep like go up to the
plate and I'm like hey I gotta hit a
homer here I think I did it one time my
whole career that's what I'm saying and
I did it when I hit for the cycle oh
okay it was a 2-0 pitch I said this is
it if I'm gonna do it right here and I
hit a home you got it other than that
it's not it's I'm gonna get out see look
at her though like when you went
back and looked at it oh you're nasty
nasty nasty and you knew he was gonna
bring his best stuff right there yeah
and so have you guys talked about it at
all nah I'm just gonna let it let it
ride let it ride I mean I'm
is a good dude man yeah like great
teammate you know just one of them guys
that wants to win you know we're both
competitive you know you it's uh
you know he's not
big cocky guy he's not you know that's
why yeah I was gonna rub in your face
yeah what's it like playing with him
every day you know what I'm saying
because you're a superstar you know he's
a superstar yeah and you know really to
be real Mikey like he's he's he's by far
the biggest superstar like I've seen a
lot of great players I played a lot of
with a lot of great players I've never
seen
these last two weeks what he's done oh
my gosh the balls he was hitting in
Texas dude
I don't even pull it up you know what
I'm saying I mean it's just like
he's special man yeah I mean everybody
sees it so what is it what is it like
his routine and everything like that and
I'm not saying you have to break it down
but like is it like simple bro simple
this is super easy super easy
um just simple man it just comes in a
cage just hit a hits a couple balls off
the tee
does some flips
goes out there and hits and that's it
that's it he doesn't do like a like a
machine I mean sometimes he hits uh the
red ball machine red ball machine yeah
like the little softballs that throw up
get some uh
but I think you know it's just simple I
think
you know he's just naturally gifted
naturally gifted I mean obviously you
know he push the work in for sure it's
pretty impressive man